тому я є тренером, який проїжджає
республіки і пробує нар
партнерство щось підходить для вас
Я вважаю, що поліція крута через це
вона задає питання, які намагається
показати, як вони здорово п'ють каву
кавовий тренінг – такий синонім
так ми можемо так часи ми можемо
давай якось зустрінемось на каву
щоб жити запитайте його стандартну ставку так
всі німці також за
насправді вони означають побачення
вона намагається справити на вас враження
задавати питання або
[Музика]
погано зберігати все інше
чесність довіра
вони разом і мені байдуже
чи родом він із глини з Німеччини
засоби не повинні зупинятися на своєму
бути настільки обмеженим своєю релігією
що це якось так старомодно
чоловіки цього не хочуть
бути обмеженим, але в іншому випадку так
якщо він відкритий до того часу з
[Музика]
не так, ти кажеш, що твій спорт так
не буває не буває що a
хороший плацдарм нейтральний чи що є
красивий вазон